[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a consulta con los
especialistas en france24 nuestro
espacio dedicado a ofrecerles
información sobre el coach 19 y nos
acompaña como ya es habitual el doctor
oscar franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y de la universidad
de erasmo de rotterdam y también asesor
científico de france 24 por supuesto
doctor franco muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos como ya es habitual bueno
la pandemia no de coronavirus ha
resultado sin duda estresante para
muchísimas personas a lo largo de todo
el mundo tanto 'el hobbit' 19 como las
medidas no para frenar lo podrían
afectar la salud mental de las personas
sí hemos visto históricamente como las
pandemias generan en la población
sentimientos muy fuertes de
incertidumbre sentimientos de
vulnerabilidad y de sospecha también las
medidas que se han tomado para manejar
la pandemia han generado cambios
drásticos en nuestras vidas como el
aislamiento físico o las cuarentenas los
colegios cerrados tener que trabajar
desde casa la crisis económica todos
estos factores se unen y generan
desafíos importantes para la salud
mental un estudio en china con más de
5.000 personas se mostraba como el 20%
de la población reporta problemas de
sueño un 15% ansiedad estrés y el cuarto
de la población depresión en un estudio
más reciente en el reino unido- con unas
15.000 personas se evidenciaba como los
niveles de insomnio pasaban del 15%
justo antes de la pandemia a niveles de
25% los meses de marzo y abril mientras
que la epidemia se consolida en el reino
unido- entonces lo que estamos viendo
son problemas generalizados de salud
mental que no están recibiendo la
prioridad suficiente para su prevención
diagnóstico y tratamiento
ahora doctor y estos trastornos del
sueño podrían afectar a alguna población
en particular
se ha visto que las mujeres se ven más
afectadas el 30% al reportado trastornos
de sueño y esto en particular es mucho
más alto en las mujeres con niños
pequeños niños menores de 5 años que
llega hasta el 40% por esa combinación
de tener que tener la responsabilidad de
la familia y las actividades laborales
de la casa también se ha reportado a
niveles de hasta el 30% en el reino
unido y un estudio temprano en la
provincia de juguetes donde empezó la
para la pandemia se evidenciaba que el
60 por ciento del personal de salud
tenía problemas de sueño y el 35 por
ciento de depresión y esto era aún más
alto en aquellos que estaban trabajando
en los servicios de urgencias y en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos doctor y
por qué es tan importante no tener en
cuenta estos problemas y estar bien
atentos
el sueño es una actividad muy importante
de hecho nuestra vida estamos un cuarto
un tercio nuestra vida estamos durmiendo
juega un papel muy importante en el
sistema inmune en nuestras defensas en
cómo respondemos a las vacunas también
juega un papel importante en la salud
mental está relacionado con depresión
también en nuestro ánimo puede generar
irritabilidad y falta de energía si no
se duerme bien y también se relacionado
con enfermedades crónicas como la
obesidad la hipertensión y las
enfermedades del corazón ahora por otra
parte consultarle qué soluciones se
podrían implementar no para ver para
prevenir y mejorar los trastornos de
sueño
unas recomendaciones básicas que me
gustaría compartir 7 recomendaciones la
primera tenemos unos horarios y unas
rutinas muy estrictas y muy claras de
cuando se va a dormir que cuando se
despierta cuando se toman descansos
cuando se cometerá segundo es hacer
ejercicio tratar de salir si es posible
si no hacer rutinas de ejercicio desde
la casa tercero seguir una dieta
saludable y evitar la cafeína en la
tarde y en la noche cuarto es reservar
la cama para dormir y para actividades
sexuales no para trabajar y no para ver
televisión preferiblemente quinto
permitir la entrada de luz natural abrir
las cortinas y las ventanas durante el
día
sexto evitar la exposición a las
pantallas de los celulares de los
computadores estamos todo el tiempo
trabajando en cámaras y séptimo tratar
de evitar las siestas o reducirlas al
máximo porque puedan generar un
descontrol en los periodos de sueño en
la noche si estas recomendaciones no se
pueden seguir y el problema continúa es
muy importante buscar ayuda profesional
doctor oscar franco como siempre
agradecerle su presencia tan útil
de france 24
muchas gracias por favor gracias a usted
ya nuestra audiencia como les decimos
siempre traten de cuidarse lo más
posible y continúen informando se en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com
[Música]